Russia's power comes from the force of
its intellect and that's on display here
at the trecek oaf gallery where the
country's most iconic modern artists
hang from the walls it got me thinking
what is art really an object an idea but
young an expression of a super personal
alien impulse that creativity imposes on
its creator oh this one swirly
I wonder what this app does
[Music]
this app gets 5 stars for sure
[Music]
it's called Prisma and its creator
alexei moisten cough uses machine
learning magic to rebuild your photos
into something that could hang in a
museum
this painting is done by alexander extre
does it look like one of your filters
yeah it's similar to a gothic filter in
our app what would presumably pick up on
yes so for example like finding the
right colors finding the right shapes
for example these circles and then it
will try to find the right structure in
your photo and redraw it from scratch
Prisma top 2 million downloads a day
earlier this year they program a vast
network of computers to study great
artists and then repaint your pictures
from a blank canvas
compared to that Instagram filters are
weak sauce they just tweak the color and
exposure of your photos how do you train
a neural net to do something like that
you need only once insta light picture
so you take like a Picasso and then and
then a lot of a lot of a lot of simple
photos and then use Picasa
to transfer that Picasso style up of
these details art accomplished
you
you